hello welcome to this week's Lawai
YouTube's favorite show hosted with me
yay leave your entries in the subreddit
Bros and I'll watch submissions in the
next episode of the why 500,000 lives
that's all it took to force - air to be
part of this do you know what we're
doing hi
I mean a watch Hermes thank you the old
become like a big blur after a while
what do you say yeah but why YouTube's
favorite show roll the intro leave your
entries in the subreddit predictions
what do you expect to see ok attention
the androids led it's that I'm not a
robot symbol hey look it's you I do
literally everything in this channel is
what I like how they just want me you
know replace everything that I do
[Music]
what do you mean records themselves
laying game which millions of people are
doing consider original content yes
preach it reacting to his fans mean not
consider original content Wow
my 9 year old I am so afraid this is
thing like you're just playing a game
it's not your game nothing nothing has
changed I have always been unoriginal ok
you read the first one I read the first
one making a meme in English so Feelies
can read it I don't making a meme in
Italian so much that can understand
daily me me nah
whoa
bark bark edgert walk you get the best
fine arts no one takes this amount of
time for me they don't just say they
took 20 hours or 50 hours this is so
cute
can we hit 5000 likes on this video
well you lowball them and they'll be
like maybe we do wow they're 9 years old
they don't know what they're doing I
think means in which some arts and you
can both understand them scream at me me
piano so he could possibly she says
Christ oh my God thank you
I know I will be stronger you haven't
seen my clients eating a picture of what
he did it he did it
he actually did it next video I gotta
say that for next one I'm sorry I will
do it well done thank you for not dying
by the way I really appreciate that
and you see there you have it everybody
you're culturally insensitive Casey
Logan I'm vegan I wish I had that card
my friend Martha so the expected Brett
right but I'm here
who's saying you're not Lego Star Wars
[Music]
I'm down to play with you but not for
the nine year olds okay moving on
celebrates 10th birthday
you gotta do what you gotta do you gotta
grow up it's part of life okay
PewDiePie Wow ready cutie pie green pea
deep a pink spaghetti guys this is a
real moment she's not spaghetti that is
racism and I will not tolerate any
racism against my spaghetti girl Frank
you that's pretty gay you know that's
really good I don't know why I said
pretty good that's really good
yes suck like I really thought you would
it really looks like it no that's why
it's funny he went through a weird face
we all do it there's no shaming in it
yeah welcome to the line thank you very
much
how does it feel that's pretty much
everything on this channel I don't get
it either
up your game pills damn are you
diagnosed with leg ma no that has to be
paid you don't leave my someone and gets
lock on back I know you did I asked
where she was from and she said I'm
Russian I asked oh she knew exactly who
I was and wanted a picture this is so
wholesome and sweet can we buy a
PewDiePie's in you saliva merch that
doesn't ship to Russia thank you guys
don't judge me okay
I get enough judgment from these guys
for some reason in the game there's an
option to undress his eight-year-old
you know clapper was invented by best
your feelings I mean it makes sense you
know Logan Paul versus ksi that's what
we need everyone want me to fight it's
kind of like it's like they're
complaining this is what they do they
just complain all the time they want the
old outra back we want the old p25 back
how about no that's ridiculous
see how now I'm on their site judge
you're sentenced to death for the murder
of four children get the capture of this
man he's free to go
yeah I decided okay we have three more
means how old is PewDiePie 28 years I
have three more years
wait what do you mean three - Morgan is
not even your almost twenty minutes as
my sister-in-law is we can that be cute
if she react okay so I know except you
she said it's okay if I show a couple
things
is that a cool transition that you call
enough issues beautiful funny
everything that weird yes her name is
Marcia and I remember yeah I think yeah
did you like it yeah yeah showing me but
at the same time you know yeah all right
you didn't even have a Facebook yeah I
mean I only stalker one opposes building
ties to learn one Italian world I don't
know 20 mm well I guess I'm learning
Italian bow Bella max yeah coming to
vibe any volume be so much yeah
thank you for guardo Nvidia video poon
you that's like Bhutan no they
understand yes that's it thank you thank
you myself for hosting this week of the
why with me very nice okay my day PT pie
with a 600 I'm taking over YouTube
trying to get like him bro fist to the
face can you keep up with the pace and
I'm never gonna switch but can you do
this
how's it going bro got together like
this when you want to hit a flow
grinding like open up up and the top
I'll never stop run up in the city and
I'm never gonna flop then we win ago I'm
like whenever I'm done with this pass
the mic to Edgar
you
inside ten minutes